la rentrée n'a lieu que dans trois jours
mais déjà les enfants ont pris
possession des lieux l'école accueille
près de 900 élèves de la maternelle au
CM2 alors que les neuf classes
disponibles sont prévues pour en
contenir moins de 500 de nombreux
villageois ont été obligés de déménager
à cause des sécheresses successives
changer d'école ça a été dur dans notre
village on n'avait pas assez d'eau même
pour un petit élevage ce n'était pas
assez
était difficile à la fois pour les
récoltes mais aussi pour trouver de
l'eau la cantine scolaire est souvent la
première motivation des parents pour
envoyer leurs enfants à l'école la
scolarité de plusieurs centaines de
jeunes que directement dépendre des
récoltes des villages environnants le
directeur lui est dans l'impasse face à
l'afflux des demandes et en appel au
gouvernement
quand vous regardez l'école primoine
[Musique]
il y a des classes inachevées un peu
partout vous voyez et
on a besoin aussi d'appui mobilier c'est
à dire les tables bas et l'équipe
n'a besoin de fournitures Emmanuel
scolaire malgré les difficultés la
situation s'améliore au Niger l'état
entrepris de remettre en marche 29
centres de regroupement 7 sont
fonctionnels pour cette rentrée dans la
région de tilaberry ces écoles grandes
capacités peuvent accueillir au total 52
000 élèves supplémentaires à travers la
région mais depuis notre arrivée depuis
que le plan de la République a fait de
l'école sa priorité tout le monde s'y
met et aujourd'hui je crois que
l'ensemble des repas l'ensemble des
problèmes la majorité des problèmes je
crois seront résolu de cette rentrée là
et vous allez voir qu'il y aura une
rentrée plus ou moins normale que ça
soit sur le plan national qui s'assoit
au niveau des centres de regroupement et
là où c'est l'éducation à certaines
urgence qu'on est en train de mettre en
œuvre l'objectif de l'administration
Bazoom d'ici la rentrée le 3 octobre
terminez la formation de 5000
professeurs pour rééquilibrer le nombre
d'élèves par classe